there's this place called the actors
station and they have an instagram and
they post
um little snippets of actors
and interviews with with some advice and
every time sometimes i'll just come
across that and be like
oh that was useful that was nice to be
reminded i feel like it's all stuff that
we know
instinctually but you just sometimes
need to be
reminded and just hear it again is there
anything in those interviews that you
wish
was asked more often about other actors
and their
process that i don't know would be
interesting or helpful to you
um i mean i'm always very relieved when
people are asked what their process is
and they're like i don't know
when it's like you know meryl streep
being like
it's different every time i'm like thank
god because that's how i feel i'm like
what
um but
i guess yeah maybe just like
what's the first thing that they they do
when they
get a script yeah i feel like where to
start that's always kind of the hardest
part
so it's different for you on every
single film but do you have
any constants where it's just like i
don't know
marking up your your script or i don't
know even just having like a specific
drink on hand or any kind of routine
element
i mean i'll read it over and over again
and sometimes i'll record it
and listen to it and go for a walk i
find that like
moving and changing scenery helps
um i was doing that a lot with miracle
workers
um just recording the scenes
and then and then listening to them and
then you know
a cup of tea or something or seltzer
you